in a follow-up statement to vanity fair
simu reveals quote my recent comments on
the ending of kim's convenience were
never meant to be a massive bombshell
expose
nor was i trying to call anyone out
specifically
these were a string of thoughts that
came from a deep and personal
perspective
that is incredibly nuanced i think
there's great potential here for kim's
convenience to be
[Music]
more than a store he also goes on to
praise the show for breaking new ground
and giving him his first big break
taking on a much different tone than his
facebook post last week
where he accused its largely white
creative team of resisting his
suggestions and pitting him and his
fellow castmates against one another
cimu's co-star jean yoon also recently
posted and backed up his lack of
diversity claims tweeting
the cast received drafts of all season 5
scripts in advance of shooting because
of covet
at which time we discovered storylines
that were overtly racist
and so extremely culturally inaccurate
that the cast came together and
expressed concerns collectively
in another tweet she as in part the lack
of asian female especially korean
writers in the writers room of kim's
made my life very difficult in the
experience of working on the show
painful cbc the network behind the show
has remained fairly silent about simu's
facebook post
which came a day after the broadcaster
had announced he would be
a co-creator on a new cbc gem series
called happy again
in a brief statement a cbc spokesperson
said simply
kim's convenience had a great run on cbc
and we're excited about simu's new
project
it's not our place to speak for the
producers or see mu liu